joining us now guy entering year three
it's already year three for matt
patricia as head coach at the detroit
lions coach good to see you yeah great
to see you guys thanks for having me on
i appreciate it no you the man you know
this is this is my guy right here yeah
it's one of the few sane people that was
in the new england building
and i mean i just have so much respect
for him and i and not only his football
knowledge his work ethic everything
about it it's top-notch and uh i'm
always rooting for you i hope you know
that thank you no i do i do and you know
i feel the same about both you guys and
and how great you are to uh to me and
obviously you know our history is
awesome too so when he was in new
england who was the person responsible
for locking him in a closet and keeping
them there because that's basically what
i probably was the guy letting him out i
probably was the guy that was like hey
where are you all right come on let's go
back out let's go talk let's get caught
up and see what's going on no doubt yeah
the godzilli though george gottsie at
the time was my gatekeeper who was
always putting me back into the dungeon
yeah he was getting rid of you and i was
trying to play y'all back up yeah he's
trying to pull you back yeah sorry
george
so you know it's been an interesting
ride for you in detroit trying to change
culture trying to bring some of that new
england way the patriot way but also
being your own guy remember you're
telling me a couple of years ago i'm not
gonna try to be bill belichick i'm gonna
try to be my own guy how have you tried
to balance taking the lessons you've
learned from a bill belichick with your
own unique style and personality yeah
you know i mean i think um it's it's
it's always hard you know you're trying
to balance all that and i would say that
it is you know for us it's trying to
build the lions way you know that's what
we're trying to do we're just trying to
be our own team uh and really what you
do is you have your foundation you have
kind of what you believe in and that's
what we're trying to impress upon our
team but as now we're kind of getting to
those stages where we grow
and we shift our own kind of method
that's really what's fun now because it
is really just what we're trying to do
more so than what anybody else but you
have to have a foundation to start from
uh you can't just go in there without
that so we've established that and i
think we've really grown a lot from that
aspect and you know you just kind of you
know year two even just the little
things um you know it's funny we talk
about it all the time uh getting ready
for training camp and i'm walking the
fields my first year and i'm like oh
these tents are too close to the
sideline what if someone catches a nine
route like it's gonna be in trouble here
and just not having to do those things
year two makes that whole process that
much easier and uh you know we just
build as we go there's just a lot of
little detail things that are already
kind of set in place from that aspect i
feel like the perception doesn't meet
the reality with like the public and how
they view you like it bothers me what do
you think is like the biggest
misconception about you and your tenure
in detroit i appreciate that um i would
probably agree you know from that
standpoint but you know probably most
it's my fault too i don't really uh let
my my normal personality out there that
much
i'm always just trying to be protective
of the team
i'm also very conscious of my kids you
know i'm real protective of my family
and so for me uh i know that you know my
my boys in school they have to deal with
a lot my wife she has to deal with a lot
so um sometimes in those situations i'm
just trying to you know protect my
family protect our team uh and i don't
really get to have those unfiltered
moments or those kind of cut-up moments
uh where everybody sees that so that's
probably the biggest yeah that seems to
be one very clear similarity to bill
belichick because i've always perceived
that guy that his flatline and you never
see any of his personality it's all
about protecting the team protecting
something other than uh himself and and
not allowing himself to be viewed as
somebody who is
funnier and looser and and not that that
robot that we see behind the podium i
mean he's honestly he's like my best
friend he's one of the greatest guys in
the entire world so um i i i understand
that and i but i get you know get to see
all that other side but it is similar
where you know when you're in this
position you just understand um i'd
rather have the shots coming at me i'll
take it it doesn't really matter you
know as long as uh our players are
protected our team's protected you know
my family's protected um i it doesn't
matter for me i just you know i want to
do what's best for those guys
you have played mahomes the chiefs
really you guys i'm not trying to be a
jerk you blew the game yeah you had them
this year i mean you had them appreciate
that all right that was great thanks
it's nice
that's how it gives you the look yeah no
it was a soft landing it was 100 like
hey that was a really good game you
really stunk it up there i appreciate
that thanks you know don't worry about
that don't worry about that touchdown
return for 100 yards don't bring up all
those memories where we drop kelsey on
the you know gotta have it play or let
you know mahome scramble at the end to
win the game it's good i got it okay
sorry all right good i went below the
belt so now we can we can get through
that but like what what is it what you
had some success slowing them down what
what is it like defending him in that
offense well you know i mean obviously
it starts with andy reid you know been
going against him for a long time i have
a tremendous amount of respect for him
uh he's a great coach he's a great guy
he's great person great coach great
leader um so it starts there he's really
probably one of the guys especially
early in the season uh you know when you
have to play an andy reed team that
you're like oh don't play them early
because they are so more advanced than
anybody else in the early part of the
season
yeah it's rolling right and you know
when you're a defensive coach and you're
trying to build defense through the
course of the year you're sitting there
going in september october going i'm not
going to have enough for this like this
is going to be it's going to be an issue
right or a season opener like you had to
deal with them a few years ago and he's
firing at a thousand you know cylinders
and you're like hey we got like three
defenses in right now i hope we can kind
of build on that a little bit but uh i
think it starts with him mahomes is
phenomenal i think they have great
players i think obviously the defense is
playing complimentary football now
their team is much different now than it
was when we played it yeah you know like
every great team at the end of the
season they evolve they change they
adapt uh they get better
so early in the year thought we had a
good plan we did a couple really good
things against them i thought played
them hard played them tough i was proud
of our guys you know wish we could have
finished it better but you know you go
to andy you go to the quarterback that's
where it's got to start when you're
looking at this team and so if you were
getting ready to play them now
given where they are right now given
what you've seen from them what would be
the message to the team to the coaching
staff what would be the goal to try to
outscore the kansas city yes well you
know i think at this time of the year
it's really the same you know it's going
to be all playoff football and
championship football it's going to
start with the run game you know
stopping the run running the ball
covering kicks but i think that's really
hard for people to understand when you
think about kansas city because how
explosive they are vertically down the
field but if you allow that quarterback
to run you know if you allow him to take
over with his feet you're gonna have a
lot of problems so it might be
controlling the run but through the
passing game and the pass rush and
making sure that you take care of that
from that standpoint um one of the
things i think that's you know mahomes
has done such a good job of is with
their skill players when they're at full
strength with hill with kelsey uh you
have to play them you have to play them
in certain in certain ways so coverage
wise uh they're not seeing as many
coverages as maybe you go into a
different game with so it's pretty easy
for him to recognize and some of those
deals where you know hey everyone's got
their back turn you know you're you're
in major help in the d part of the field
that rush gets out of lane just a little
bit he's gone and that's the part that
can frustrate a defense the most so you
have to be very very disciplined up
front you know if it's a third down
situation and you know you let your d
line rush past the quarterback against
this guy you know it's just you should
know that ahead of time and you're gonna
be a lot of trouble well when you say
that like there's coverages you can and
can't play and you almost gotta like
simplify like what why like what is it
what it is about their skill set and
everything i think it's just how
explosive they are and you know how fast
and how much you know how many times
they can score yeah so uh you want to
make sure you're in a situation where
you know if you you're going to take
your chances and you're going to pick
your spots right where you want to be
aggressive and get after them a little
bit more but
i think you just you know how dynamic it
is if you miss up you know one play one
assignment it's you know it's a
touchdown right it's not a big play
right they're gone they're gone you know
they're gone and that's the hardest part
for it is is the
is there anybody comparable to like
defending mahomes through your years in
new england anything like that um is it
rogers-esque i mean that's the guy i
kind of fall on but is it is it that or
is it totally different it's a great
question you know i think um
there's guys that are similar from that
aspect aaron rodgers is great with that
you know obviously um you know different
but similar would be just those guys
that can threaten you you know with
their feet at any time and take off and
go um so from that standpoint there's
similarities but he's just you know i
think he's
so much more advanced and he's grown so
fast right with andy from you know
playing him early and playing them young
where he didn't really see him see some
things or maybe he's kind of reading
that first read and uh maybe waiting
till they get open before he throws it
now that thing is like the read is the
progression is you know all right here's
one here's two here's three yeah i'm
gone right and it just happened so fast
i think his decision making has really
improved yeah is it is it as simple as
and i think about the bill belichick
mindset take away what the opposing team
does best right is it is it simple
enough to just say drop everybody back
and force them to be slow and methodical
and patient and take what's available
underneath and and take away that 50
yard touchdown it could be the back
brake yeah i mean i think part of that
you know you can mix that in but i don't
think this is a this is not an offense
where you know call it the bend but
don't break i think at some point you
break you know so there's going to be
those opportunities where you have to
take those chances and you have to be
aggressive uh with them you know and you
know there's there's definitely um
situations when you play an offense like
this where they can score you know
you're trying to gain an extra
possession so there's going to be
something else in the game whether it's
a special teams play uh an extra
offensive play for your offense uh
something where you're trying to gain
just
one last time that he has the ball you
better prepare for shanahan in the super
bowl yep tell us like what what what is
it like what are you worried about when
you got to play kyle kyle uh he does he
does an unbelievable job he's really
he's one of those guys that i really
admire from a coordinator standpoint and
a game plan standpoint
obviously as a head coach but i mean i'm
talking about specifically game plans so
when we look at other opponents or we're
looking at things and i'm trying to
figure out you know different
plays or schemes that have worked
offensively i'm gonna watch his offense
i'm gonna i'm gonna look at how he
attacked the opponents because i think
he does an outstanding job of finding
the weaknesses exploiting him uh putting
his players in in great position to make
great decisions good plays and just
managing the game you know he does such
a good job with jimmy uh who's obviously
great you know knowing him sure uh as
close as we do uh just putting him in
those positions where he can have
success and i think that's what kyle's
doing a great job he's really putting
his team he's playing that complimentary
football where his team is just in
position to have success yeah
let's talk lions for a minute
martha firestone ford came out near the
end of the season the time when there
was a lot of speculation about what
she's going to do and is she going to
make changes she made it clear she's
going to stay the course but
her message also seemed to be hey
next year's a big year we expect a
winner in 2020. i mean how much how do
you balance appreciating the support but
also
it's it's kind of clear that that the
expectations are high going into next
season sure um well you know i think it
kind of let's split it up into two
different categories um you know i meet
uh with mrs ford and her family and the
organization all the time you know we
have open conversation uh every week
we're in you know great discussion about
the organization what we're trying to do
and what we're trying to build you know
from that aspect of it um it's it's
certainly an organization where we're
trying to improve every aspect of what
we do um and certainly you know we're
we're trying to get there obviously our
record was not good and uh you know your
record is what it is and that's what you
are but uh i do feel that the growth
part of what we were trying to do was
there and i think she recognizes that
too which is which is great and and i
appreciate that um you know i think it's
so hard nowadays everyone wants instant
information for instant success and um
you know quite frankly uh things that
you know are meant to be great they take
a while uh and you have to allow some of
that to develop and grow and and i feel
we have good players we have good guys
uh they're great in the community you
know they're doing things that are
important um and i think that's all
recognizable um so that's kind of one
side of it i think the other side of it
the expectations that never changes you
know everybody's always got to win
there's only one team happy at the end
of the year uh i'm not even happy to be
in you know miami unless i was playing
uh it just it's a mindset change it's
different than probably a lot of people
think but you know as far as i'm
concerned um you know it's it's one team
everybody else is the same and right now
for uh you know for me i approach every
season same every game i expect to win i
expect us to go out there and play hard
compete and uh you know we'll just go
from there so i don't really worry about
that part well we got to make it known
here too i mean listen yeah i know the
year didn't end up the way you wanted to
but when you lose your best player on
your team arguably matthew stafford i i
will sit here and go the year was gonna
be different yeah i mean he's a
difference maker and then he got screwed
over in green bay by some bad calls i
mean those are some of the worst calls
of the year they affect your life to
where now like the owners making
decisions but like talk about matt
stafford and what he brings to the team
when he is out there healthy i
appreciate that and that's why i love uh
you doing your job cause you say those
things that i could say you know
that are so good to say
you know because my message is gonna be
the same i don't really care who's
playing we're gonna find a way to win
right be competitive uh but i'll say
this about matthew stafford uh
unbelievable guy he's amazing uh really
going back to last spring and um you
know putting a new offense in you know
hiring a new offensive coordinator
trying to develop and grow him as a
player um and all the things that he had
going on man he's the same guy every day
he's tough he's smart he's the most
amazing thing about i'll shoot him a
text like hey what do you think about
this guy i could be talking i'm telling
you it could be a pop warner kid in like
dearborn like you know b team and he
would know him he's just a football
junkie and i love it you know i love
getting in those meetings with him and
talking about defense and what i see and
what he sees and um and he's just tough
he's competitive and he's just an
outstanding leader you know there's
nobody that those guys don't get fired
up for more to go play and you know he's
extremely talented on top
so
all that in effect uh um it's one of the
reasons for me um that i you know he is
one of the reasons i left new england
you know there was a lot of
opportunities that i had but um to go be
around a guy like matthew stafford for
me um it was a great opportunity to grow
as a coach and be able to be around a
great player so from that aspect of it
uh you know i couldn't be more more
happy yeah there he is matt patricia
lions head coach we wish you all the
best 2020 and beyond and thanks as
always for some of your time yeah it's
great to see you guys always i
appreciate you more than you know
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports